which scene in the batman has given
audiences chills even robert pattinson
was caught off guard by the scene plus a
behind-the-scenes look at how the
detective elements came about all that
and more right here people seem to love
the batman with robert pattinson in the
mass the caped crusader's latest solo
adventure sees him responding to a
series of murders perpetrated by a
villain calling himself riddler to solve
the crimes and prevent anyone else from
dying batman will have to descend into
the seedy underbelly of gotham to
uncover the truth unraveling a
conspiracy in the process that threatens
everything he once believed about the
city from batman beating up a group of
thugs harassing an innocent man to the
thrilling car chase involving batman and
penguin there's plenty to sink your
teeth into and naturally fans have taken
to social media to voice their love and
admiration toward the film hyping it up
one scene in particular appears to have
stoked fans excitement and the good news
is that it comes early in the film's run
it's become commonplace in batman movies
for the opening scene to revolve around
the villain for the dark knight that
involved a thrilling heist involving
joker and a few other nobodies wanting
to steal the mob's money in the dark
knight rises director christopher nolan
up the ante yet again by introducing
viewers to bane in high-flying fashion
as he hijacks a plane the batman carries
on this tradition by opening the film
with riddler spying on the home of
gotham city mayor don mitchell jr he
then cuts to riddler inside of his house
ready to strike and instill fears into
the hearts of gothamites it's incredibly
effective at establishing the film's
tone and displaying how much of a threat
riddler is this isn't just a guy telling
riddles as he's been portrayed in other
batman media he's a terrifying serial
killer to the point where the scene
feels more like something out of zodiac
than a superhero movie it's proven to be
so effective that numerous people have
taken to social media to say how much
they love the sequence one twitter user
wrote the opening scene is so powerful
and one of my favorite scenes in all of
film those sentiments were echoed by
another user who had this to say
can't stop thinking about the batman and
that opening scene definitely not gonna
be able to sleep much tonight
it seems as if the impact of the scene
isn't lost upon later views either as a
third user wrote that opening man second
time seen it and it still sends chills
it isn't just casual fans who are being
taken aback by the batman opening scene
either prior to the film's release
robert pattinson spoke with variety
about the movie and even he admits that
when he watched the sequence for the
first time it was unlike anything he had
seen before the actor mentioned i
watched a rough cut in the movie by
myself and the first shot is so jarring
from any other batman movie that it's
just kind of a totally different pace
pattinson went on to say that the tone
of that scene was pretty much what
director matt reeves had envisioned
doing from the very beginning it was
what matt was saying from the first
meeting i had with him i want to do a
70s noir detective story liked the
conversation and i kind of assumed that
meant the mood board or something the
look of it but from the first shot it's
oh this actually is a detective story it
may take some viewers by surprise to see
batman in full noir mode but he's the
world's greatest detective for a reason
and that reason is something pattinson
only learned after he nabbed the part
there's a lot of stuff where he's in
amongst the cops normally when you see
batman he arrives and beats people up
but he's having conversations and there
are emotional scenes between them which
i don't think have been in any of the
other movies
indeed from the opening scene to the end
credits the batman is unlike any caped
crusader movie that's come before and it
sets a new bar for the future of the
franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]